it's a long way from Manchester but West
Palm Beach and Florida is where the odds
shortened on a sale of the rent
on streets populated by the super rich
we tracked down one of the money man
minded to sell
avram Glazer club owner Mr Glaser why is
now the right time to sell Manchester
United hi well as we announced yesterday
the board went through a process and
it's decided it's going to look at
different strategic Alternatives and
that's what we're doing so United fans
say that you should have sold the club
years ago
well once again we've gone through a
process we're going to look at all
different all strategic Alternatives and
we'll see where that leads us so I
appreciate you talking to me tonight and
I'm going to wish everyone a Happy
Thanksgiving Cristiano Ronaldo says that
you don't care about the club and
thousands of United fans agree with him
why why should they be wrong well I'll
tell you about Cristiano Ronaldo he's a
great Manchester player I appreciate
everything he's done for the club and I
wish him the best luck in the future
thanks very much why did he have to
leave the club why did he have to leave
the club before he began World Cup Duty
Cristiano Ronaldo had left Manchester
United with a part in short at the
Glazer family saying they didn't care
about the football side of the club
many in the support have long been vocal
in their disdain of the Glazer family's
ownership
Manchester United fans have made their
feelings clear here in Florida the
supporters trust has written to the
Glazer family
urging them to sell and sell quickly
saying the last 17 years have been
characterized by debt and decline on the
field and of it the fans trust told them
they would carefully scrutinize any new
owner it is the supporters demand to be
heard when the money talks James
Matthews Sky News in West Palm Beach
Florida